There's an old native american proverb
that says
inside every person there are two bears
forever locked in combat for your soul
one bear
is all things good compassion love
trust the other is all things
evil fear shame
and self-destruction
what's happening. we have to run! As fast as you can! Wait!
what's happening!
here
hide here I have to go help them
No no, dad. Please please don't leave me alone
Dani, I have to go back stay here
All of you have killed someone
if you weren't here you've be in prison.
or worse
New mutants are dangerous
we know
this place takes your greatest fear
and makes you live through it
what are you doing you've got to get
better someday
Demon bear let's play a game!
New mutants are dangerous
and they need to learn how to control their powers
Welcome back everyone happy comic-con
week they just dropped the opening scene
the full opening scene from marvel's new
mutants they had a big comic-con panel
so i'll explain
what's going on there's a bunch of
easter eggs they even made some jokes as
you can see
about the release date it's good that
they can actually make fun of themselves
if you're new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get everything they're a
bunch more comic con trailers that'll be
dropping today tomorrow and saturday
i'll try to do as many videos as
possible
we'll do a new amazon giveaway all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and let me know where you want to see
other x-men
show up in the mcu during marvel phase
4. the big thing with this opening scene
is that you have Dani moonstar
narrating her native american mythology
that her family gave to her about demon
bear about demons
inside them some are good some are bad
obviously that's a reference to the
literal demon bear character
while they're showing you her reliving
this big attack on her family and her
people that they were living around
even though they don't explain what's
going on exactly like they say that
you're here because all of you different
kids
killed someone you'd be in jail if you
weren't here
this is demon bear in real life trying
to gaslight them
making them think that they did all
these things when really it was him
when really all these bodies in the
death of her family like her father's
like i have to go help him and then he
runs away and it's implied that he died
that's demon bear
killing her family in the past it seems
like when this is happening even though
she's reliving this memory
this is around the time that her powers
are manifesting for the first time they
kind of did that during the first brian
singer x-men film where you see rogue's
powers manifest for the first time as
she becomes a teenager it's usually
around puberty that mutant's powers
start to manifest
you get a bunch of new scenes with the
characters using their powers the
special effects look way more polished
we finally see maisie williams in full
wolfsbane form
you see Magik using her powers in a
bunch of different ways way more complex
so it seems like she's actually way
better using her abilities than the
other members are
but the whole thing with demon bears
that he's this supernatural entity that
consumes the souls of people and in the
very first new mutants comic book story
way way back he has this fixation on
Dani moonstar
and it's a story of her coming together
with the other initial members of the
team
to learn the truth about who and what he
is and master their abilities and work
together as a group to stop him from
killing dany and then everyone else
he also draws extra power from negative
human emotions so you can see
why he's trying to trap them in this
weird reality of the mental hospital
you see him use psychic projections from
each of the different team members minds
to try to get them to relive their worst
moments to get them into this heightened
state
the more they freak out the more power
he can draw from them
then as he gets more and more powerful
you see the full-on battle like the big
Magik vs demon bear fight in limbo
Dani moonstar's code name in the x-men
comics is mirage
she also has the ability to create
mirage-like apparitions based on
people's worst fears so demon bear seems
like he's using that against her and
maybe also against the other team
members during the movie
like celia reyes the nurse character
here who's also an x-men comic book
character with her own powers says
during the footage she acts like she's
helping them but her power is also
creating force fields and you see them
start to bang up against some of her
force fields trying to exit the doors
they keep talking about being trapped in
this place so demon bear might also be
manipulating celia reyes too using her
powers against them to try and keep them
trapped here because one of demon bears
other abilities is also corrupting
human souls his other major abilities
include teleportation just like you see
Magik teleporting all over the trailer
footage
in transformation he can change his form
it seems like they're combining some of
his backstory with the limbo dimension
in Magik's backstory too though
but it's clear that Magik understands
her powers just a little bit better than
the other members because you also see
her manifesting her magical armor her
magical sword
while also teleporting around some of
the team members here seem like they're
just learning about their abilities for
the first time like they know that they
have
some kind of ability but they don't know
exactly how it works so they don't know
how to use them together as a group to
defeat demon bear
but that's part of the arc of the film
is that they all use their abilities
together to defeat him
even though there's that funny video of
them making fun of all the different
release dates that they've had for the
movie
during the comic-con panel they didn't
address anything about rescheduling
again disney hasn't officially said that
they've rescheduled the movie
even though nobody is expecting this to
still come out august 28th
literally while i was making this video
disney just delayed all the avatar
sequels
the mulan movie in the next major star
wars saga of movies a full year
in advance because of the virus no word
on what's going to happen with the black
widow movie later this year but that's
not out till november so
by the time we get a little bit closer
disney will probably have a better idea
what they're going to do with it
they had some weird language when they
were talking about what's going to happen
with the mulan movie
that might serve as an example for what
will happen with the black widow movie
they said that they're exploring
alternate ways to get people to see the
movies so i think that just implies that
they're going to have a hybrid
release where some places in the world
they'll release it in theaters where
theaters are open
and where theaters are closed they'll
release a video on demand
there's already a bunch of movies that
are hitting video on demand instead of
going to theaters in the next month or
two so
just stay tuned i'll do a new video when
they announce what's going on with the
movie
right now all the disney plus marvel
shows are still going to be dropping
before the end of the year the falcon
and winter soldier episodes the Wandavision episodes
the mandalorian season 2 episodes those
will all be happening before the end of
the year so don't worry there will be
big content
in amazon's the boys season two episodes
are also starting september 4th i'll be
doing weekly episode videos for that
if you haven't watched it yet it's
amazing it's basically a parody of the
avengers in the justice league dc comics
there's going to be a bunch more
trailers this weekend we have a special
justice league snyder cut trailer that's
coming on saturday so as long as you
have alerts enabled for my channel you
should see all the videos when i post
them
there will be a couple other big
trailers this weekend there was a big
wolverine video that just dropped so
i'll try to do videos for as many of
those things as possible
while you wait for everything everyone
click here for that brand new justice
league snyder cut trailer announcement
and click here for that brand new boys
season 2 trailer
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe i'll see you guys tonight!